IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT BACKING DOWN
IN THE BATTLE OVER HOW TO DEAL
WITH THE CARAVAN.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING THAT HE
WILL STOP MIGRANTS FROM ENTERING
THE UNITED STATES.
>> WE ARE SENDING A SIMPLE
MESSAGE TO THE LAWLESS CARAVANS
AND ILLEGAL TRESPASSERS MARCHING
FORWARD TO OUR BORDER.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
TURN BACK NOW, GO BACK HOME.
WE WILL NOT LET YOU IN.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET YOU IN.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACCUSING MIGRANTS IN THE CARAVAN
IS USING CHILDREN AS HUMAN
SHIELDS AS BORDER PATROL AGENTS
FIRED TEAR GAS SUNDAY.
>> WHY IS A PARENT RUNNING INTO
AN AREA WHERE THEY KNOW THE TEAR
GAS IS FORMING THEY'RE GOING TO
BE FORMED AND THEY ARE RUNNING
THERE WITH THE CHILD.
IN SOME CASES YOU KNOW THEY ARE
NOT THE PARENTS.
THESE ARE GRABBERS.
THEY GRAB A CHILD BECAUSE THEY
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A
CERTAIN STATUS BY HAVING A CHIL
CHILD.
>> Dana: COUNSELOR TO THE
PRESIDENT OF KELLYANNE CONWAY.
>> THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA ONLY
WANTS YOU TO SEE THE CHILDREN,
THE FAMILIES.
THEY ARE NOT TELLING YOU MOST OF
THE CARAVAN ARE MALES TRAVELING
BY THEMSELVES, THAT OF COURSE
PROJECTILES AND ROCKS WERE
THROWN AT OUR BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN AT THE BORDER AND THEY
USED NONLETHAL FORCE IN RESPONSE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES MAKE SURE THAT
OTHERS WHERE THERE ARE NOT ARME
ARMED.
>> Dana: A POTENTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN LOOMING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP REPORTEDLY
DEMANDING $5 BILLION TO BUILD A
BORDER WALL.
LET'S GET TO THAT IN A MOMENT.
GREG, HOW ARE WE GOING TO WRAP
THIS UP DOWN THERE?
I DID HAVE A REPORT EARLIER
TODAY ON "THE DAILY BRIEFING,"
THAT THERE WERE TWO --
>> Greg: WAS CHRIS DYER WALT
ON?
>> Dana: TO BUSLOADS OF
TEENAGERS DECIDED TO GO HOME.
>> Greg: SMART MOVE.
ONE OF THE BURDENS OF BEING OF
-- A CONSERVATIVE IS WE ARE
STRAINED WITH THE LAW AND ORDER
PRESUMPTION THAT WE WILL ALWAYS
BE ACCUSED OF LACKING
COMPASSION.
NO WAY OUT OF IT.
IF YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE OR
RIGHT WINGER OR LIBERTARIAN, YOU
WILL ALWAYS BE SEEN AS
INSENSITIVE ESPECIALLY IN
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS, YOU'LL BE
ACCUSED OF BEING CRUEL BECAUSE
THEY WILL HAVE FOOTAGE OF TEAR
GAS AND PEPPER SPRAY TO MAKE
SOMEBODY LOOK BAD.
THE PROBLEM IS IT'S IT'S
ACTUALLY THE OPPOSITE BECAUSE
WHO WARNED THAT THIS WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN?
US, AND WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS, WE WERE ACCUSED OF BEING
EXPLOITIVE.
EXPLOIT NATIVE.
>> Dana: BOTH WILL WORK.
>> Greg: WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS HAPPENING IN SAYING THAT IT
WOULDN'T END WELL, THE MEDIA
LAUGHED INVESTMENT AND WHAT
HAPPENS IN A DOESN'T END WELL,
THEY BLAME US.
SO YOU CAN'T WIN AND IT'S
ACTUALLY WRONG.
IF THE CONSERVATIVES AND THE
PEOPLE FOR LAW AND ORDER AND
CONSTRAINT THAT HAD THE BEST
INTERESTS FOR THIS GROUP OF
MANIPULATED SOULS.
THESE ARE SOULS WERE BEING
MANIPULATED BY ACTIVISTS AND
IT'S A PERSUASIVE LEFT-WING PLOY
TO DO THIS KIND OF THING.
IT NEVER ENDS WELL FOR THE
PEOPLE BEING USED.
>> Dana: JESSE, I TALKED TO
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL AT DHS
WHO SAID, I ASKED THE QUESTION,
WHAT DOES SUCCESS LOOK LIKE TO
YOU IN A MONTH AND THEY SAID AN
ORDERLY PROCESS FOR ASYLUM
CLAIMS TAKEN PLACE IN MEXICO,
THAT THEY THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO GET TO ANNEX THEIR
GOAL.
>> Jesse: IT'S A GOOD GOAL.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
NOW THAT I AM A DOG OWNER, DANA,
I AM MUCH MORE COMPASSIONATE.
I FEEL LIKE THESE PEOPLE DESERVE
A CHANCE AND I LISTEN TO GREG
AND I SAY YOU CAN BE
COMPASSIONATE AND BE FOR LAW AND
ORDER.
>> Dana: YOU CAN BE A
COMPASSIONATE CONSERVATIVE.
ESPY I JUST SAY THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
THE PERFECT PERSON TO ARTICULATE
THAT.
LISTEN, THIS HAS TO BE FIXED
SOON.
NOT ONLY DO THE PEOPLE IN THE
NORTHERN'S HAVING THE BORDER
DISLIKE IT, THE PEOPLE IN
TIJUANA HATE IT.
IT'S A HUGE CRISIS AND FOR SOME
REASON THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
AMERICAN CITIZENS, BORDER PATROL
AGENTS, OUR FELLOW PATRIOTS,
PROTECTING OUR SAFETY, THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE BEING VILLAIN
EYES TO -- VILLAINIZED.
THIS PRESIDENT BELIEVES IN
AMERICA FIRST AND THE LEFT
BELIEVES IN BLAME AMERICA FIRST.
IT'S AN UNDERDOG MENTALITY.
THEY ARE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
BEING A WORLD SUPERPOWER SO
WHENEVER AN UNDERDOG OR THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY OR ANYBODY NOT AS
POWERFUL AS AMERICA HAS ANY SORT
OF ASSAULT ON THIS COUNTRY, THE
IMMEDIATE THOUGHT IS WHAT DID WE
DO TO PROVOKE THIS?
WHY ARE WE TO BLAME?
HOW CAN WE, YOU KNOW, ACCEPT
THIS ASSAULT AND A WAY BECAUSE
WE ARE SO POWERFUL THAT WE CAN
TAKE IT ON THE CHIN ALL THE
TIME.
THAT MENTALITY HAS AFFECTED THE
THOUGHT PROCESS OF MANY PEOPLE
IN THE LEFT THAT ARE OKAY WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE BORDER
AND I THINK IT'S WRONG.
>> Dana: JUAN, DO YOU THINK
THE DEMOCRATS ARE WORRIED THAT
THEY ARE BEING PERCEIVED AS
BEING OKAY WITH WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> Juan: I THINK WHAT THEY
WORRY ABOUT IS HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
STRUCTURE THIS AS AN INVASION,
SOMEHOW THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
CONSTITUTE A THREAT TO AMERICAN
SECURITY IN SOME CASES WHERE
THEY ARE CRIMINALS OR GANG
MEMBERS.
AS OPPOSED TO THE REALITY WHICH
IS THAT THEY ARE A DESPERATE
BUNCH PEOPLE COMING SEEKING A
TITLE.
WE HAVE FUNNELED THEM ALL INTO
ONE PLACE AND THEN WE TELL THEM
TO WAIT ON THE OTHER SIDE AND OF
COURSE THERE ARE LONG DELAYS IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESSES WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE GET
FRUSTRATED.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY BEEN
THROUGH A LONG JOURNEY.
APPARENTLY ABOUT A QUARTER TO
MORE WITH CHILDREN.
THE CHILDREN ARE OUT OF CONTROL.
EVERYONE IS FRUSTRATED AND
ANXIOUS.
>> Greg: WHO CREATED THIS?
>> Juan: I THINK WHO CREATED
THIS WAS DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: HE DIDN'T START THE
CARAVAN.
ALL IMMIGRANTS WAIT.
>> Juan: YOU DON'T WAIT LIKE
THIS.
WE'VE HAD WITH TRUMP, HE HAD
SEPARATION OF FAMILIES AT THE
BORDER.
>> Greg: OBAMA DID THAT.
>> Juan: NO HE DIDN'T.
>> Greg: YES, HE DID.
>> Juan: THIS IS ABSURD.
>> Jesse: HOW DID TRUMP START
THE CARAVAN?
>> Juan: I DIDN'T SAY HE
STARTED IT.
A FEDERAL JUDGE HAS SAID HE'S
WRONG BUT HE SAID THE ONLY PLACE
YOU CAN APPLY IS THROUGH
EXISTING PORTS OF ENTRY.
YOU CAN'T JUST COME ACROSS THE
BORDER WHICH HAS BEEN THE
PRACTICE IN THE PAST FOR PEOPLE
WHO WERE SEEKING ASYLUM.
SO THE NEW         THE -- HE PUT
SO THE NEW         THE -- HE PUP
SO THE NEW         THE -- HE PUO
SO THE NEW         THE -- HE PUL
SO THE NEW         THE -- HE PUE
SO THE NEW         THE -- HE PUI
SO THE NEW         THE -- HE PUN
JEOPARDY AND YOU CREATE ANXIETY
AND YOU SAY THEY ARE BAD PEOPLE.
>> Dana: LET'S GET MORGAN IN
HERE.
THE SHEER NUMBER OF PEOPLE
COMING OVER HAS DEFINITELY
CHANGED.
DHS HAS SAID IT'S THE BIGGEST
CARAVAN.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE BEHIND THIS
ONE AND ANOTHER ONE BEHIND THAT.
SOMETHING ELSE NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
IT CAN'T BE STATUS QUO.
STEVE ON THE LAST TIME I WAS ON
THE SHOW, YOU BROUGHT UP A GREAT
POINT.
>> Greg: STATES IN HER GREAT
POINT JOURNAL.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING HOLISTICALLY
AT WHERE THIS CAME FROM.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT A REGIONAL
APPROACH.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BORDER,
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT IMMIGRATION
OR MIGRANTS COMING IN.
90% OF THE HEROIN, THE MAJORITY
OF THE FENTANYL THAT'S GETTING
INTO THE COUNTRY GETS IN THROUGH
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
SO POLITICALLY ALL WE ARE SEEING
IS, BECAUSE THE MEDIA HAS
DECIDED IT'S POLITICALLY CORRECT
TO BE ON THE SIDE OF THE
IMMIGRANTS WE ARE SEEING OF
CHILDREN AND BABIES WHICH IS
TERRIBLE.
I COULD ALSO TAKE YOU TO EVERY
REGION OF THE WORLD.
I COULD TAKE YOU TO SYRIA,
AFGHANISTAN, THE MIDDLE EAST,
AFRICA AND SHOW YOU PICTURES OF
WOMEN AND BABIES THAT WOULD
BREAK OUR HEART.
BUT THE WHOLE WORLD WANTS TO
COME HERE SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT WHO'D WE HELP, AND WHY.
WE CAN'T DISCOUNT THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ASPECT OF THIS OF AN
INSECURE BORDER WITH DRUGS AND
MANY ILLICIT THINGS COMING
ACROSS.
IT'S A MUCH BIGGER PROBLEM.
EVERYONE IS TAKING POLITICAL POT
SHOTS AT EACH OTHER.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON GREG'S POINT.
JUAN SAID SOMETHING THAT TRUMP
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT WE ARE
SEEING.
A MONTH AGO, DONALD TRUMP WARNED
THE CENTRAL AMERICAN GOVERNMENTS
STOP IT.
WE ARE GOING TO PULL AWAY YOUR
AID.
PLEASE DON'T LET THEM COME.
HE WARNED MEXICO DON'T LET THEM
COME.
AND THEN HE SAID IF YOU COME
HERE, WE ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOU ASYLUM.
HE SAID IF YOU TRIED TO CROSS
THE BORDER, WE ARE GOING TO
DETAIN YOU AND SO WE PROCESS YOU
ARE NOT DUE CATCH AND RELEASE.
HE HAS WARNED ABOUT THIS.
HE HAS HAD THERE'S GOING TO BE
VIOLENT CLASHES.
HE HAS TRIED TO BOLSTER THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND NOW WHEN YOU
HAVE SITUATION WHERE IT ALL --
THESE WARNINGS HAVE BEEN
UNHEATED BY THESE PEOPLE AND BY
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TR
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TW
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TC
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TS
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TA
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TD
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TS
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TE
THE MEDIA, THEY GET THERE AND TD
THEM WITH SHEER GAS WHICH IS
LAW ENFORCEMENT 101.
>> Greg: OBAMA DID IT 80
TIMES.
>> Jesse: NO ONE SAID A WORD
AND THEN TRUMP IS TO BLAME,
JUAN?
TRUMP HAS BEEN TRYING TO STOP IT
FROM THE JUMP.
>> Juan: I SAID WHEN YOU
CONSTRUCT A SITUATION WHEN YOU
FORCE PEOPLE INTO AN UNTENABLE
SITUATION.
>> Greg: HE DIDN'T FORCE THEM.
>> Juan: THE FORCE OF ENTRY
ARGUMENT.
THEY ARE ALL STACKED UP.